as you all know that there is a corner
virus outbreak in China and let us talk
about what is the severity of this
outbreak what is the cause and
consequence is there any vaccine or
treatment and how coronavirus can be
detected so what this video till the end
and make sure you share this video among
your friends to grow awareness so corona
virus enters our body via our
respiratory system and primarily infect
the lungs let's look at the timeline of
this outbreak so the first incident took
place in December 30 2019 where some
cases of pneumonia of unknown origin was
detected all across China and especially
in the town 1 and it is reported to
Chinese National Health Commission after
that around January 7 2020 the novel
strain causing these out causing this
pneumonia was isolated and it is found
to be the corona virus strain
now this corona virus strain was then in
their sequenced in several labs in China
and the sequence information was shared
to World Health Organisation Health
Organization in January 16 2020 the
outbreak spreads to Japan and Thailand
and now many Western countries and Asian
countries are affected by this virus so
now China Australia France and some
places of us is also affected by this
virus and how rapidly this virus is
spreading right now from the center of
the incidence from Huang
the virus has spread it all across the
China and it's nearby countries such as
Japan and Thailand and according to John
Hopkins University there is reported
1354 confirmed cases and there are quite
a lot of death at least 41 death repor
till January 24th so it's pretty deadly
but not as deadly as Ebola virus so
coronavirus are not so deadly or lethal
but sometime they can be quite nasty so
let's talk about the corner virus for a
moment Karuna viruses are from subfamily
ortho : ability and it's order is night
ovary forget about the term they are
simply single-stranded RNA containing
viruses so RNA is their genetic material
they have an envelope and several
proteins such as s protein which has
Spike proteins envelope proteins and M
proteins which are membrane associated
proteins decorating their whole in the
ER now this corona virus is specially
target the upper respiratory tract and
the lungs now on a particular cell
surface there are specific receptors
which are like docking sites in this
case is two receptor or
angiotensin-converting enzyme receptor
is a docking site for the S proteins of
this virus this leads to receptor
mediated endocytosis a way of entry to
the host cell once inside the host cell
the virus first make several viral
proteins including capsid and the matrix
proteins and this plus sense RNA is
directly taken up by the ribosome and
processed for protein synthesis now
after that the virus replicates its own
genetic material makes more of it and
ultimately there are more viral
production and assembly taking place
inside the host cell and the virus moves
away and ready to infect another cell
which is uninfected now the viral genome
is now sequenced so the scientist can
get an idea of what kind of unique gene
present in those viruses and that genes
can be detected by PCR and this is one
of the diagnostic method currently used
to detect a
coronaviruses now in pcr you can amplify
specific unique sequences which are
unique for these Karuna viruses and
other than PCR based detection method
our body produces antibodies against
these viruses or these viral matrix
proteins these antibodies can in fact be
detected by an Eliza assay where you
coat the well with the proteins found in
these corona viruses followed by you put
your serological sample which is serum
collected from the patients and if there
is antibody produced in that special
body then these antibodies would be
attached to the antigen presenting the
will and enzyme linked sa would
ultimately tell us the presence of the
virus via a color change so if the color
change is there that means the virus is
there because the antibody against the
virus has been produced in the patient's
body currently there is no vaccine but
the scientist has no noticed that the
virus enters the cell by s2 receptor so
they tried to block the s2 receptor for
a temporary treatment and they created
antibodies against the x2 receptor till
now it is not marketed but this is one
of the promising treatment if the s2
receptor or the receptor by which the
virus gets inside the host cell is
blocked when the virus cannot get in and
as a result the infection cannot occur
but what you can do to prevent this kind
of outbreak if you notice somebody who
is having an ongoing curve or problem in
breeding immediately you should tell
them to go to a doctor and reporting to
the doctor is the most intelligent case
in this situation rather than hiding it
because imagine if you hide your case
and then try to sneeze or cough in the
public then this infection might spread
instead of stopping right you might
spread this infection and other people's
life may be in danger
so to report this case to doctor
currently there are no treatments but
going to intensive care in the hospital
there are enhanced chance that you could
get recovered from these viruses so
please spread this information among
your friends and do like this video and
share it as much as you can let it go
viral and please like share and
subscribe thank you